ce week-end commence un moment
fondamental pour la reconquête les
représentants de l'ensemble des
militants les conseillers nationaux vont
débattre entre eux des grandes lignes
politiques sur lesquels ils veulent
construire le projet d'alternance de
vous êtes les visages des républicains
vous êtes le parlement des républicains
évidemment il peut y avoir à la fois une
primaire est à la fois un projet pour
les républicains
nous les deux cent cinquante mille
militants des républicains nous
partageons des valeurs nous partageons
des idées et c'est cela que nous
exprimerons dans ce projet qui sera
soumis évidemment à votre vote d'ici
l'été
on veut du débat et que les projets
soient portées par la base et les
adhérents et les militants c'est ça en
fait le fond du fond de cet ce week-end
du conseil national c'est d'ailleurs une
promesse du président des républicains
nicolas sarkozy et républicains en
vocation à définir et à porter un projet
collectif et ambitieux dans la
perspective de l'alternance nous sommes
des cadres de notre parti mais des élus
aussi qui est une richesse pour notre
famille politique je vis sur une zone
qui est dramatique au niveau des
attentats parce que je vis au proche
orient
on peut avoir nous français d'étrangers
des idées qui peuvent être intéressantes
pour notre pays pour notre famille
politique pour construire aussi notre
programme pour les années à venir les
valeurs que nous devons porter réaffirmé
c'est l'autorité c'est la liberté
d'entreprendre c'est évidemment la
valeur centrale du mérite
et puis cette valeur que nicolas sarkozy
appelle la nation il faut que les
républicains redevienne le grand parti
de la nation française la seule
préoccupation qui doit nous guider la
seule
c'est celle de l'intérêt de la
république un voltmètre le parti de la
nation française
l'élection de luc chatel c'est un espoir
d'une démocratie qui soit attentive au
choix des militants
et donc c'est une bonne nouvelle pour le
mouvement cette démarche de faire aussi
voter les militants etc
c'est quelque chose qui a permis plus de
démocratie au sein du mouvement
c'est quelque chose de très intéressant
et je remercie président sarkozy de nous
de nous avoir permis de voter de nous
avoir permis d'être là aujourd'hui de
donner aussi la parole aux jeunes c'est
quelque chose de très important pour un
nouveau parti du 21ème siècle qui veut
construire mon ambition c'est que vous
ayez la fierté vêtements d'une famille
politique qui s'appelle les républiques
il vous pourrez dire à vos amis à votre
entourage à vos collègues à tous ceux
pour rencontrer j'ai pris ma carte aux
républicains j'apporte et tout l'amour
que j'ai pour mon pays j'ai voulu
m'engager pour préparer l'alternance je
n'ai pas été déçu ils m'ont donné la
parole ils m'ont écouté ils m'ont
entendue et le texte le texte qui sort
c'est pas forcément le texte qui a
repris toutes mes idées mais c'est un
texte que j'ai pu moi-même commenté
amendé et qui me représente
si chacun dans la famille chacun d'entre
vous chacun dans votre département
ce sont respectés alors ses 66 millions
de français qui se diront après un
pouvoir qui nous ment on a une
opposition qui nous respecte voilà ce
que je souhaite pour la france
merci à vous